previously in part one my name is Samuel
Leeds so our mission is to help
deserving people become financially free
by property that's what we do
the next crash course now is two days
I've got a lot of prep to do
[Music]
good morning and welcome to the property
investor crash course great day and then
you're gonna say my name is Sonny
Willie's so the property investors crash
course while it is just two long days
it's a lot of work not just the two days
all the admin getting all the love that
the lighting the stage the sound checks
the music the register all the admin
that goes with it
finding the venue making sure it's just
it is two days but it takes a month to
put it on if we were to stop doing it
after the baby I don't think it would be
because of the two days I think it would
because of all the stuff that you don't
see that needs to be done and I need to
be involved with that frankly yes we
have got a couple books now for early
part of next year just talking the
baby's born and we'll see what it's like
running the crash courses with the baby
does it work or does it so it could be
the last few that we ever run or it
could be that we we continue to learn
them up at the moment I don't know cool
seriously this is the best venue yeah
agreed
we've got the most people we've ever had
I think we're gonna have the most fun
we're gonna ever have I know there's
gonna do the most deals found was so be
infantile I think it's going the best
property investors crash course
[Music]
that's not the shirt that told you to
wear bit Oh who's that
no there's three and that I said the one
that's closest to sue what's the one
that's closest to you oh yeah oh I've
got a really good feeling about today I
think I think that it might be one of my
favorite crash courses but I hope it's
gonna be the last one
certainly for a long time but yeah
rock'n'roll
[Music]
good morning and welcome to the property
investor crash course welcome onto the
stage the man of the moment mr. Samuel
me
day one of the crash course is all about
how to find deals you know what makes a
good property investment how do you then
formulate that how do you work out the
return on investment how do you find it
what's the best areas HMOs single that
departments do that that's tough day one
because a lot of real super familiar
faces power has completely just failed
out of nowhere we're all set up we're
good to go we're very prepared people
with no power supposed to be
[Music]
should we start counting
[Music]
everybody joy this is very intelligent
people well I just think
[Music]
maybe it's me
so the next session or I'm gonna find a
house in front of everybody life I hope
to find a house first orgy do it
completely no I do it completely live so
that fun
I find the house on the spot you got to
do a live man yes this is a raw live
real business you can't be pre planning
stuff man because how are they going to
expect to find a house live I don't do
it so I got to find it live now what
your point is we will probably look at a
lot of properties that are on auction
50% house share and a lot stuff ah
that's so interesting like just like to
flick through the people that come they
were all a little bit unsure they're
strangers and they're sat next to each
other and you can just use telephones
thinking of what is going to happen
what's this about and day one just
seeing people transition from sceptical
novices to a real family you know by the
end of day one everyone's everyone's
really close really connected they're
partnering up with people that joint
venture Inc so just to get that real
family sense by the end of day one it's
just incredible I was thinking around
about lunchtime I was thinking the
energy feels a little bit below you know
are they getting it but man they are
alive they're on fire that's why I'm
here I feel like I'm born to do this
[Music]
one of the things that you're gonna have
to expect to get if you put yourself out
there if you're if you're if you wanted
to make a big difference in the world
you're gonna get a lot of pizzas
especially behind the keyboard we call
them keyboard warriors now never never
once I've had someone say to my face I
don't like what you're doing you're
referred none said that but behind a
keyboard you get people saying all kinds
of stuff it's just going to happen and
what I always say to myself is for
everyone hater
you've helped 100 day to is how do we
leverage and money to buy lots of these
properties without using any of our
money really well they're currently
practicing their roleplay on lease
option agreements
I'm interested in seeing the results a
lot of my staff so Tonya Elliot and Max
and the guys you know I see them in the
office working but seeing them at the
crash course empowering and helping
others in their property journey seeing
them on such a bus and seeing them
operating in their highest sense is
great for me as well we have a really
really amazing group they're asking all
the right questions
they've done their background checks
they've read Samuels book they have
watched all his videos they've done and
done and done them done to the really
really experienced group actually now
I'm considering I've had the promotion
of from by low rent high as managing
director I have now promised the
delegates that I will go through the
properties they sourced so yeah they've
all messaged them and links are coming
in Fast and Furious people come to the
crash course to learn and they come to
learn about property one guy that came
Stewart brought his son Richard he
dragged his son along because he wanted
Richard his son to learn about property
and although they both learn about
property his Richard was so pleased with
his dad for bringing him and at one
point which had got up on stage to share
what he learns and he was so overwhelmed
with joy that his dad and bore Jim
we called his dad up and these two
father and son suddenly despite begging
and started to cry at how overwhelmed
with joy they were not just because they
learned about property but because now
they've got and financially for their
life that was going to set them up but
who's gonna give me freedom plans for me
watching these two grown men father and
son on stage I'll give and crying that
that really I don't think I'm ever gonna
forget that ever gonna forget that
moment the great thing about the
property investors crash course is that
some people say you can find the
information online and what else you can
find some of the information online you
could spend months and months trolling
through the internet look in all
different sites or you could spend two
days having a condensed crash course not
only talk to you but also where you're
made to take action and actually
implement the stuff there and then on
the weekend seeing people come in that
don't know even how to work out the
return on investment to actually on
their laptops finding deals securing
properties and working out all the
figures and the formulas I just get such
a person seeing people come on it's such
a long ways to shorten that time and the
energy
celebrations the vibe is just incredible
is it's it's a real mountaintop moment
for me in the concluding part we are off
to pick up some baby things well